hey here's some good news and we we've
been looking for good news lately in a
new poll john fetterman the democratic
candidate in um pennsylvania's senate
race is ahead of mehmet oz the
television doctor by 11 points this
genuinely is good news if oz were able
to defeat fetterman
it would be a disaster now
there's still some disaster in here but
we'll talk about that in a second
democratic candidate john fetterman is
leading mem at oz by 11 points that's a
fox news poll
the poll and remember fox news polls are
not particularly bad polls um the poll
released thursday found fetterman is
backed by 47 percent of voters oz is
backed by 36 percent so it's an 11-point
lead now it's still horrible that an
out-of-state television grifter can get
36 support
at the same time
i think about 36 of the country at least
36 percent of the country believes the
earth is only six thousand years old
so
it's maybe not that shocking but the
important thing here is let's not assume
that this is over this is a critical
absolutely critical senate race if you
break down there's a bunch of different
scenarios that you can outline
um but most importantly
if you say
which one race could control of the
senate hinge on there's like a handful
of such races
and um one of them is the pennsylvania
senate race so
if you're from in the state of
pennsylvania
you must vote you must vote we all must
vote and if you're from outside the
state of pennsylvania you're still
allowed to phone bank you're still
allowed to donate or lobby for donations
fundraise whatever uh very very
important race and again we don't we
don't concede races just for the hell of
it but given some obscure race in a
extremely red district for congress
and this senate race when we think about
the potential consequences this senate
race is pretty pretty high on the list
so an important one to get involved in
we're going to continue covering it
11-point lead is good a lot can happen
in the next three months and it is now
only three months until those midterms
and we'll continue covering this one